I have only ever hit about 50 000 in a
year I do Instagram marketing for
personal Brands and
up for about five years
hit a hundred thousand this year and I
know I can do it and I know that's just
the beginning and I'm wondering like
what advice would you give
the fact that you can create the number
100 000 concerns me by making a number
that's double and immediately puts
pressure on yourself having the mindset
of how to get to a hundred I think is
what's interesting actually getting a
hundred is not important you work hard
but don't make up a number why not 200.
I would love 200 so why didn't you pick
that
[Applause]
[Music]
somebody who says I'm worried about
putting pressure on myself creating a
number immediately puts pressure on it
go for 400 but put yourself in the thing
where you're not keeping score just
worry I'm doing good work and being the
best content producer you can make I
just I want to have fun you won't have
fun if you come up with a number that is
hanging over your head like a noose
you'll have fun if you know I'm gonna go
hard as [__] period